bah moi pardon je suis beaucoup plus
sévère d'abord ça fait rire l'avocat je
comprends pas depuis tout à l'heure il
rigole et depuis tout à l'heure il dit
même pas il regrette le président de la
cour d'appel rien aussi pendant le
pendant
très drôle mais bien sûr parce qu'en
fait vous rendez pas compte dans quel
point ce geste a une valeur purgatoire
pour des Français cercle des Français
qui sont maîtrisés au quotidien vous
n'êtes pas les autres arrêtez de faire
parler
les gens qui savent pas quoi dire moi
les Français me disent attention tout ce
que je vois c'est que c'est un monsieur
aujourd'hui vous avez un petit peu
s'énerver parce qu'on a déjà reçu une
fois il avait présenté aucun regret vous
non plus vous d'ailleurs
ça vous fait rire c'est pas drôle ce qui
s'est passé
dans la République il a frappé une
fonction il a humilié un pays je suis
désolé Macron comment quand il a vu des
humoristes à l'Elysée c'est mon avis je
suis dans la rue pour quelqu'un d'autre
je peux marcher tranquillement les gens
viennent parce que vous me remercier
comment ça se fait que les gens viennent
pour me remercier ces trois dans la rue
non non non non non c'est des gens que
je ne connais pas tu me reconnais pour
lui donc vous les connaissez pas vous
pensez que les Français
c'est des enjeux qui sont fondamentaux
c'est des enjeux qui sont extrêmement
d'actions différents il y a d'autres
moyens
quels sont les moyens d'action qui sont
disponible on a vu les gilets jaunes
quand ils ont fait bornier quand ils
sont fait gazer quand ils essayent de se
faire entendre c'est ça les moyens
d'action qui aujourd'hui dans ce pays
qui a été frappé quelqu'un
on a braqué une arme à feu sur moi c'est
pas de la violence
à feu sur moi
une arme à feu est-ce que ça c'est pas
de la violence je connais pas la
situation c'est parce que vous avez fait
monsieur
et ça va être compliqué pour lui de
rester dans ce pays et ça c'est une
question qui devrait nous interroger je
suis pas en train de valider des
ambiance
de la politique président de la
République se retrouve dans une
situation d'être confronté à ce genre de
de geste et comment ça se fait qu'il va
demain aujourd'hui dans son propre pays
avoir du mal à pouvoir sortir dans la
rue
si je peux me permettre
contraire Juan Branco je vais vous dire
Emmanuel et Nicolas Sarkozy c'était
compliqué c'était compliqué pour lui
aussi avant chaque soir
Jacques Chirac c'était compliqué il y en
a pour qui c'était pas compliqué parce
qu'il dit rien c'était François Hollande
non mais c'est vrai voilà François
Hollande on savait on savait même plus
qu'il était président ça vous intéresse
pas que dans un pays dans ce pays en
fait on arrive à un niveau de violence
vis-à-vis des institutions et des hommes
politiques qui sont ces représenter tout
le pays mais qui fait ce qu'il y a des
gens qui viennent féliciter Monsieur
tarel dans la rue c'est pour son geste
avec les gens en tout cas
sur 15 minutes
pardon je vais vous défendre un peu donc
laissez-moi vos voilà
Mathieu il y a quand même jamais eu
autant de personnes soit dans la rue
soit dans la merde soit violente soit
victime de violence donc ça c'est quand
même un fait ensuite attends attends
que ce soit une gifle ou que ce soit en
fariné c'est un symbole alors oui chez
des c'est un grand pas
même sur la tête
dramatique de lever le main sur le
président
maintenant la question pardon Guillaume
je peux finir pardon par contre la
question de dire est-ce que ça a été
enfin est-ce que votre sanction est trop
légère moi les gens qui disent ça c'est
incroyable parce que si vous avez des
mois de prison en plus vous serez limite
autant autant inculpé que quelqu'un qui
a violé ou tué des gens parce
qu'aujourd'hui
les institutions respectables et donc
des institutions respectées aujourd'hui
à chaque fois tous les soirs sur le
plateau on dit que ce n'est plus
respectable parce que ça parce que ça
marche sur la tête